the Joe Rogan experience I first heard
your story decades ago
I've told you last night we went out to
dinner I've seen pretty much every
interview you've ever given I've
followed the story incredibly closely
but for people who don't know the story
let's give them the bullet points you
used to work at area 51 and area 51
you got you you went like huh well you
know we want to be accurate Oh carry s 4
s 4 okay it's about 15 miles south of
area 51 okay um you worked in what would
you how would you describe it I guess
within the area 51 compound you can call
that a subset of area 51 and you got
that job before that you were working
before that I had worked at Los Alamos
right National Labs in New Mexico and
you were involved in what kind of work
the nuclear weapon development physics I
mean that's they do everything there so
how did they approach you to say hey Bob
once you come on out to the Nevada
desert well the way this went down was
at that time it was 1982 I put a jet
engine in my my Honda and Los Alamos put
it on the front page of the paper said
you know Los Alamos man physicist at the
lab you know built this 200 mile an hour
you know on the jet car that I drove to
work every day so so I was known in Los
Alamos that the guy with the weird car
and you know you could hear it from you
know a mile away anyway
the day that came out on the front page
of the paper was the day Edward Teller
the father of the hydrogen bomb was
giving a lecture down there at the lab
and we didn't have much going on that
day in our group and I asked if I could
go down there and I went down there
early and Ed teller was outside leaning
on a brick wall there and reading the
front page
the paper now there's a guy out of
history so I introduced myself hey I'm
the guy you're reading about there and
we talked for a little while and it was
cool you know fast forward two years
later I had moved out to Las Vegas and
had you know left Los Alamos and you
know went on to other things and I
wanted to get back into the scientific
humanity yeah I left start other
businesses and and that sort of thing so
I sent resumes out and one of them went
out to ed teller and referenced our
meeting you know back it back in that
the day and anyway he remembered me and
gave me a reference somebody to contact
at EG&G and that's pretty much how it
started so you get a phone call or a
letter like what do you get well I got a
what did I get I got a letter initially
and went down for an interview probably
a couple times and it was down at EG&G
special projects which was at McCarran
Airport at that time out in Las Vegas
and did they give you any sort of job
description what you were applying for
they said it was for ed I can't remember
exactly what they did this was a long
time ago but I think it was advanced
propulsion or something like that
something relatively generic and they
said it's in a remote area you know it's
gonna be some days on some days off and
you know it was kind of a it was kind of
not exactly a full-time job but you
might have to be out there for two weeks
at a time and take two weeks off so it
was kind of a the work schedule would be
kind of broken up and did this seem
attractive you or did it seem weird no I
really wasn't weird because people that
work at the test site anybody that's
familiar with the area up there you know
working at the nuclear test site or at
the Tonopah test range north of there
that's typically how things go so you
had known about it from the scientific
community because the area 51 at that
time was about area 51 okay so they just
said it was in a you know in a remote
location and you just know it was up at
the 10
site right so but there was no mention
of area 51 at that time so they've done
hundreds of nuclear tests in Nevada
Nevada that that whole area was there's
been just giant chunks of Nevada the
people yeah there's a big piece of
Nevada and it split up into different
areas there's a nuclear test site
there's area 51 there's the Tonopah test
range north of that there's little sub
areas there's areas where they test
chemical weapons and things like that so
it's all broken up as a you know
gigantic test area so take me back to
first day on the job you accept a job
they take you out there yeah it's the
first day really I didn't really get to
see a whole lot the first day was
essentially just paperwork that's when I
flew into area 51 proper and I left
McCarran Airport and flu what they call
the Janet flights just you know a
passenger plane from Las Vegas to area
51 and it was really just going through
a mountain of paperwork that day from
security clearances to God there was it
was like two or three hours of just
solid paperwork and that was that was
really an uneventful first day
[Applause]